Speaker 1: As the December six runoff for the
Georgia Senate election gets closer and closer,
one candidate, Raphael Warnock, is making
more and more sense. The other candidate,
Herschel Walker, is increasingly unable to speak.
We're going to look at clips of both options that
Georgia voters have on December six. Remember
that if you vote in Georgia, the Senate races
are not over. We know Democrats will control the
Senate, but will it be 5050 or 5149? That's going
to come down to a runoff election in Georgia.
The reason there is a runoff is that Georgia
has something called the 50% rule. The 50% rule
states that if not, if no candidate in a regular
election gets to 50% of the vote, the top two
vote getters will have a runoff. And indeed,
although Raphael Warnock got more votes than
Herschel Walker, neither candidate got the 50%
because of a third party candidate. And so there
is going to be a runoff on December 6th. Herschel
Walker in a completely deranged weekend saying
things that don't make any sense about anything.
Here he is in one clip, blaming Raphael Warnock
for a disruption to his speech that was caused
by an ambulance driving by. Listen to this.
Speaker 4: One. I'm not worried for God. He
sit down here. We get this man out of this. I'm
not a warrior for God to sit down here because I
don't dance and sing for nobody. I never have
and never will. But I remember my wife Islam
used to tell me there's a horse are. Follow me.
I take you to the promised land. So tell all,
you vote for me. We all get to the Promised Land
because we're not going to get there by one hour,
all of us to get together because that's what we
are. We're God's people. And we got to get that
together. We got to work this thing out together.
Speaker 1: We can. You guys following this?
Speaker 4: Do it. Gold in the Bible. Ari, is it a
house divided? Cannot stay in the Bible. Senator,
why not read it? But it's not the Bible I've been
reading because you don't seem to be doing the
right thing by him. That must be said. Or why not
doing this right here? Trying to cancel me out.
But he can cancel me. I'll go. I'm a man of God.
God love me. And I can tell you that right now,
he loves me. I'll tell you this right
here, because we're getting cold outside,
but cold weather only make us bed. Yeah.
Speaker 1: Really? Just commenting on everything
from police responses to godliness and weather and
just everything. At another event, the trend we
saw was that Walker's attacks on Warnock became
not only increasingly incoherent, but also sort
of strange in this word salad. Walker tosses
up the idea that Warnock is not God's people.
Speaker 4: But I started watching television and
I came upon a man by the name of Rafi Awana. Well,
this was so funny. I'm getting to it. No, no,
don't. Boom. He's. He's everyone fall short of
glory, God. And think about it. And he is
all watching him. And just the other day,
I heard him preaching in his church about me
losing. Some of the things I see is venomous
and violence. And he said that, you know, when
you talk about him, you're talking about Jesus
and you're talking about Dr. Luther King. And this
was your point about it. He is correct. When you
talk about God's people, you sometimes talk about
Jesus, but he's not God's people because he's not
doing right by what God is telling him to do.
Speaker 1: Crystal Right. Crystal Clear. Folks,
this is an election that is less about any
particular issue and more about values,
consistency, and who do we want representing
us in the Senate? Big picture. And that's
what I'm going to come back to after we
look at the Raphael Warnock clips. Now,
just one more of Herschel Walker blaming
Warnock for something related to Archie
Bunker not being on TV anymore. I mean, these
are it's almost like a random word generator.
Speaker 4: I'm glad he is a man on a call for not
having read the Bible. I read God. He talks about
forgiveness. They say, don't forget this speck
in your brother's arm to get the point in your
own life. You got to ask for forgiveness. He
never asked for forgiveness and moved on. He's
talking about the past. We don't want to live
in the past, but you all can. I tell you this
either Archie Bunker, when you be on air today,
would know. And I tell you how you do what Archie
Bunker did. You not like Archie Bunker? He called
and said in a word, no, it wouldn't be on air
because he's still living in the palace. You got.
Speaker 1: I don't know what he's talking about.
It wouldn't be a Archie Bunker went off the air
in 1983 and the guy who played Archie Bunker died
more than 20 years ago. It's just that this is not
about which candidate's tax policy do we prefer?
Okay, this is absurd. Now, on the other side
of this, we have a very good candidate and
uncontroversial good candidate. Here is a
viral ad that Raphael Warnock put out in
an extremely sophisticated way, equating
Herschel Walker's policies to dog poop.
Speaker 4: Is it just me or does it feel like
we've been here before? The whole country still
is voting and only us left. You'd think Herschel
Walker would want to explain what he'd do in the
Senate if he actually wants to represent Georgia.
Instead, he repeats the same lies, trying to
distract from what we all know is true about
him. But I think Georgians will see these ads
for what they are, don't you? I. Rafael Warnock.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So anyway, he dumps dog poop into
a trash can when he says, I think people will
see his lies for what they are. And then here
is Raphael Warnock, making sure people understand
this from just a few days ago. There is going to
be a runoff. There is another election coming.
Speaker 4: Well, Georgia, here's the deal. It's
now clear our race is going to a runoff on
November 8th. The people of Georgia showed
up. You showed out while we received more
votes than my opponent because we came up
just shy of 50% of the vote. We're going to
a runoff. So I'm going to need all of you,
every single one of you to go and vote. One more
time. On or before December six. This runoff is
about who is ready to represent you, who will
actually work for Georgia. It's about who will
stand up and fight for a better tomorrow for all
of our children. Early voting runs November 28th
through December 2nd and runoff election day is
December six. Now, nobody believes a preacher when
he says in closing. But I'll close with this. Go
vote. Your vote is your voice, your voices, your
human dignity. And Georgia, I need you to raise
your voices again louder than ever. Are you ready?
Because I'm ready to keep working for Georgia is
out of my life. Let's do this thing one more time.
Speaker 1: All right. So there are no shortage.
There is no shortage of opportunities to get
involved. You can, of course, donate. And many of
you wrote to me and said, you have donated. You
can phone bank. I believe that a Cuban-American
streamer, Steven Kenneth, Destiny Bunnell. The
second is going to be leading a coalition of
canvasing. Down in Georgia, I don't have the
details in front of me, but I believe it will be
the weekend of. You know, I don't I think it's
the first couple of days of December. But we can
get that information. We have to get involved with
this one. If Warnock wins, you knock out the power
of mansion slash cinema like, yes, there's still
two of them. You need one of them, but you can
lose one of them and still have 50. And that is
of critical importance. And we are going to follow
this one. This is the race at this point in time.